in this video we're going to talk a
little bit about momentum and i
encourage you to think about what does
momentum mean in everyday language if i
were to tell you that a business has a
lot of momentum
many people would imagine that means
that it's doing really well it's hard to
stop that business from succeeding if i
were to tell you that and let's say a
movie star has a lot of momentum it
means that they keep making really
really really good movies it's hard to
stop them and in physics momentum
essentially has that same notion in fact
these everyday language versions of
momentum really came from the physics
version of it and an informal definition
you could think of it is how
hard
to stop something
stop something so with that very
informal definition we'll get a little
bit more mathy in a few seconds i have
two pictures here and let's say this
both of these vehicles so we have a big
18-wheeler truck here and here we have a
formula one car let's say that they both
have a velocity
of
20 meters per second
positive 20 meters per second we'll just
think in one dimension so it's let's say
it's going to the right at 20 meters per
second so that's a magnitude and a
direction that okay we've got a positive
here to make it clear that i'm giving a
direction here so they're both
going in the positive direction at 20
meters per second but you can imagine
their masses are very different
this large truck would have a mass of
let's just say 30 000
kilograms that's roughly actually what
an 18-wheeler truck mass is i looked it
up before this video and let's say the
mass of this formula one car
is about 1000
kilograms
now pause this video and think about
which one do you think would have more
momentum
all right well you're probably imagining
trying to stop either of these and i
guess either of these would be difficult
to stop but a truck going at 20 meters
per second seems a lot harder than the
formula one car this thing like seems
like it would just be able to drive
through anything so if you picked the
truck having a higher momentum when it's
going at the same velocity as a formula
one car you'd be right
but an interesting question is well how
can i quantify that and that's where we
have the mathematical definition of
momentum and momentum
is defined as mass
times velocity
and because velocity is a vector it's
not just a magnitude we assign a
direction so we said in the positive
direction if we're in one dimension we
said in the negative direction we'd be
going to the left that's maybe the
convention we could use
and since it's a scalar which is mass
times a vector momentum is also going to
be a vector you're going to have a
momentum in a certain direction
so pause this video and see if you can
calculate the momentum for each of these
vehicles and see also if you can figure
out what the units are going to be
all right now let's think about the
momentum for this 18 wheeler it is going
to be its mass
which is 30
000
kilograms
times its velocity which is positive 20
meters per second and so when i multiply
those two things i am going to get let's
see i'm gonna get a six with
one two three four five zeros one two
three
four five
zero six hundred thousand and then the
units are kilogram times meter per
second
kilogram
meter
per
second
that's the momentum of the truck now
what about the formula one car pause the
video and try to calculate that momentum
all right well same notion i'll have to
squeeze it in right over here the
momentum here is
the mass 1000 kilograms
1
000
kilograms times the velocity positive
20 meters per second i'm stressing the
positive because we're in one dimension
and i'm saying positive is one direction
negative is the other direction so i am
giving a direction here and so this
momentum is going to be equal to
20 000
kilogram
meters
per second kilogram
meters per second and so when you
evaluate the momentums it's clear
mathematically that the truck has much
more momentum
than this formula one car it has 30
times the momentum
now i know what some of you all are
thinking well this is just from the
reference frame if i'm standing still on
the ground while these while this truck
and car are moving by
but what if i were moving along with
them would they have the same momentum
and if you were asking that question
it's a very good one and the answer is
no the momentum depends on the frame of
reference so let's say that you are able
to travel very quickly in well let's say
you're you're in a car here
and you're also going at 20 positive 20
meters per second you're going the same
direction as the truck
well relative to you the truck's
velocity is now zero so from your frame
of reference if you wanted to calculate
momentum you would have the mass of the
truck 30 000 kilograms but from your
frame of reference the velocity would
now be zero so if you're traveling in
this car at the same velocity as that
truck your the momentum you would
calculate is zero
now what would then have momentum well
in that world let's say that there's a
big rock over here
that
let's say this thing 100 000
kilograms
well when you were standing on the
ground that thing would have no momentum
but now that you're moving 20 meters per
second to the right positive 20 meters
per second
the rock in your frame of reference
would look like it's going at negative
20 meters per second it would look like
it's going 20 meters per second to the
left and so this would now if you're
moving in the same frame of reference as
that truck this rock would then look
like it has a very negative momentum and
i encourage you to calculate it if you
like but i'll leave you there this is
really just an introduction to momentum
but once you get an intuition for it all
sorts of interesting things in physics
start to emerge from it